all right let's get to some of your
emails tweets Reddit posts smoke signals
and telegrams that have come in over the
last week or so you can always email
info at davidpackman.com if you have
feedback for us and let's just get right
into it Melvin peachy
came I don't know why I find that name
funny Melvin peachy says
dude you need Jesus how can you mock
people and their faith there is
t-h-e-r-e which is the wrong there
listen Jesus is not for me
um mocking people and their faith listen
this is not about mocking anything that
brings meaning to individuals
when we get to a point in society
where
beliefs that make no sense literally
are being imposed on civil government to
make law then I have a problem and yes I
may on some level mock those beliefs
there when it comes to private religious
views if you want to privately believe
and Noah's ark or
the Zeus or Thor or that you know a
Jewish Carpenter was the son of God born
to a virgin died then came back to life
and walked on water or whatever if you
want to privately believe that and not
impose it in any way
on civil governance and the way that
this country runs
okay go ahead and do it right I mean I
don't think it's accurate but go ahead
and do it but the second that these
right-wing extremists introduce
religious justifications for telling
women what they are allowed to do with
their bodies in consultation with
doctors as well as I guess your your
sacred texts now are part of the
consultation no and at that point we're
going to say this doesn't make any sense
and
um I don't believe that the left should
apologize for that believe whatever you
want to believe but don't not only don't
impose it on others don't use it as a
justification for civil government to
run in any particular way and that is
absolutely my position uh craigson says
about the mass shootings that we
continue to have in the United States
we've become numb to all this horror
that in itself is an indictment of
American culture and government policy I
could not agree more and this is
something I I was recently I was
recently interviewed for a forthcoming
written profile which I'll share with
you when it's published and the topic of
sort of becoming desensitized to
Insanity came up
and I do everything I can
as someone who covers a lot of these
sorts of things on a daily basis I do
everything I can not to become
desensitized and you know during Trump
by the thousands time thousandth time
that he does something Bonkers like
using a Sharpie to draw on a hurricane
map or sending a reporter out of the
room like they're being sent to the
principal's office it's important to
fight normalization and Hyper
normalization of crazy things and I try
to remind myself of that but I admit
it can be tough
not to become desensitized to some
degree
and the mass shootings I mean on any day
of the week you can go to gun violence
archive and look at the last 72 hours
and you'll see individual gun homicides
and mass shootings every single day and
sometimes they don't even really make
the news it's an absolutely terrifying
reality
uh but it is where we are right now
and we have to find a way to do
something about it post it to the David
packman show subreddit by lochnar asking
opinion on Tulsi gabbard as Trump's VP
pick writing I think Tulsi might be an
option for Trump's VP pick as she would
fulfill the requirement of being a woman
as well as being a Russia Putin
apologist I think her not being white
could easily be spun into a positive for
racist right-wingers she's proven to
have no limit when it comes to debasing
herself for her own personal gain and
might pick up some low information
voters that still think she has some
credibility or Integrity the whole being
disillusioned with and leaving the
Democratic party could be turned into a
strength most of all I think she fits
Trump's image requirement that he wants
someone that looks like they're from
Central Casting I'm not trying to be
sexist myself writes lochnar but looking
at the situation from Trump's
perspective and how image obsessed he is
I don't think he'd go for someone like
Marjorie Taylor green for that reason
Nikki Haley I guess would be the most
obvious choice but I really think the
possibility exists for Tool C to get
picked I'd probably put her before
Carrie Lake anyway with her just
basically being a sore loser anybody
else think this is possible yeah I mean
so I have two thoughts on this one I
don't believe Tulsi gabbard is going to
be Trump's VP pick but I agree with all
of the reasoning that lochnar uh lays
out for why Tulsi would actually fit
check a lot of the boxes she would be a
I'm reading uh the late David graber's
book BS jobs
and he talks about one category of BX BS
jobs is uh uh box Checkers so to speak
and Tulsi checks a lot of the boxes
she's not tough on Putin which works
well for Trump
um she has even though the right now
says they're against identity politics
she actually checks some identity boxes
that would allow those on the right to
say see we're not sexist we're not
racist it's a non-white woman I I mean I
guess I guess Tulsi gabbard's not white
it's not totally clear she's half
she's native Hawaiian I think or native
Native American I'm not actually sure uh
I don't do the identity thing so I'm
actually not sure what the deal is with
that she left the left which is super
popular you know Dave Rubin made a bunch
of money by leaving the left and and so
she has that I agree a hundred percent
for a bunch of reasons tool C would be a
great pick for Trump I don't think she
is who Trump is going to go for from the
YouTube channel Dynamic photography says
about gun violence there was an insane
amount of murders by stabbings and
vehicular impact over the weekend as
well are we going to discuss Banning
knifes
knives and vehicles as well news flash
we need to get to the bottom of our
mental health epidemic ASAP it's way
deeper than the tool that's used well
again we need to do both I am with
everybody on the right who says we need
to deal with the Mental Health crisis in
this country it would be nice if some of
the right-wingers saying that were
willing to actually put some money
towards funding dealing with the Mental
Health crisis many of them are not
willing to do that but I will go further
if we have mentally ill people some of
whom are prone to violence as the right
loves to say and they might have access
to knives vehicles and guns wouldn't we
want to restrict their access to guns
like do we want mentally ill people
predisposed to violence to have AR-15s
now you could say well they also
shouldn't have a knife they're going to
be able to kill way more people in a
short period of time with an AR-15 than
they are with a knife and then you know
often they go to this vehicle thing yeah
you can use Vehicles as a weapon but
Vehicles primarily have a completely
different purpose that is not to shoot
people oh but guns can be used for
target practice okay yeah but uh uh uh
the the the the primary function of the
history of a firearm was as a tool of
war and as a tool of killing not as a
tool of target practice primary function
of a vehicle it's transportation and so
they they get all mixed up about it it's
kind of sad to see but we've got to keep
rebutting it because they keep saying it
Matt whites posted to our Facebook page
conservatives Time After Time come
around only when it happens to them they
are binary zero-sum immediate
gratification thinkers without the
capacity for empathy until it lands on
their lap I am afraid that the majority
of gun fetishizers and second amendment
contortionists will keep at it until the
accumulative corrosive effects on
society force their hands by then it may
be too late for civil America yeah I
mean we've seen many anti-gay
Republicans who all of a sudden their
nephew comes out or their daughter and
they change their View and unfortunately
that's going to take too long and it's
impractical when it comes to waiting
around for that to happen with gun
violence it just doesn't make sense and
it would be an insane amount of death
and destruction so I think that I think
the comment is correct
personally facing gun violence might
change the views of some of these
Republicans some would not change their
minds
um but that we can't rely on that as a
way to fix the problem Frederick Simon
said on Facebook
I'm sorry to say it but I think a lot of
American people are willing to destroy
the country because they think Biden
will not make it through the entire next
presidential term if he wins and the
vice president would take over this is
the only reason I can think of because
if Trump wins we know where the country
would be headed a dictatorship
yeah listen I I'm not a hundred percent
sure I understand this one but I wanted
to include it because there there is
something really important here
would Trump
turn the U.S into a dictatorship if he
could
I think it's plausible that he would you
know when George W bush said this would
be a lot easier if it was a dictatorship
or whatever the case may be
I don't think Bush would turn the
country into a dictatorship given the
opportunity
I do believe that Trump actually would
but I don't believe he's going to really
get that opportunity and I know every
time I say this people write to me they
say David that's dangerous for you to
say that because you're minimizing that
no no no no I'm not minimizing the
threat I've been crystal clear about the
dangers presented by Trump
I do not believe that if Trump got four
more years he would turn the U.S into a
dictatorship even if that would be his
preference if you disagree with me let
me know Michael wrote in with a podcast
question says hey David uh Mike here
long time viewer first time emailer I
saw you on Lex Friedman's podcast which
is great I've been watching both of you
forever it made me wonder
when someone like you does a podcast
such as his is there payment involved
for that matter do any podcast guests
get compensated or do people view it as
an opportunity to get their name out
there thanks in advance okay
we have never paid
any of the thousand plus guests who we
have interviewed and I have never been
paid to be on any podcast either
that being said we have been asked for
payment a couple of times by guests I
won't tell you who they were they
actually weren't really big names it's
interesting the really big name seem to
understand you either do it or you don't
it's either worth doing or you don't you
either have time for it or you don't but
you don't you don't ask for money
mid high level guests
are the ones who have asked for money in
the past is this a paid appearance we
would do a pay uh and the answer is
always no
and uh I believe this is basically
always the case now the exception to
this would be
if you get invited like right now for
example I'm uh in the middle of talking
with a it's not a podcast it's a show
that films in a different part of the
country
and
there they do offer compensation it's
not a podcast appearance it's sort of a
program that is being cast and there's a
there's a fee and they pay travel it's
sort of a different thing but as far as
podcasts like ours we have never paid
anyone I have never been paid and I have
never heard of anyone being paid okay
Richard Harris commented on YouTube
I find it incredible that so many
Americans could even contemplate voting
for Republican candidates after what
we've seen of Republican policies
particularly with regard to abortion and
other health care issues is stupidity or
ignorance mostly to blame well stupidity
and ignorance are kind of the same thing
I think the the better question is are
is is it stupidity is it selfishness or
is it a complete disregard for other
people that is to blame and I think the
answer is it's a combination of all of
those things and I've spoken about this
extensively before and unless we deal
with all three of those aspects I worry
we're not going to be able to get out of
this sort of Doom stupidity cycle in
which we find ourselves today let me
know what you think stupidity uh uh
stupidity selfishness or or lack of uh
lack of concern for others which is more
to blame and what proportions send in
your emails info at davidpackman.com
remember that Monday Memorial day we'll
be doing a one-day membership special
it's going to be explosive like nothing
you've ever seen before if you've been
thinking maybe I'll sign up I don't know
it sounds kind of interesting Monday
Memorial Day is a great day to do it
all you need to do in order to be
notified about the Monday membership
special is to get on our newsletter at
davidpackman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show we'll see you back on Monday